I mean I've watched this these guys
attacking suddenly these guys are paired
from somewhere where the sticks these
looked like Commandos
and I thought you know they're here to
defend me because you know my life is a
threat so the the judge had ordered that
I have to be protected so I thought
they'd come to defend me and I thought
God looks like there's some terrorist in
the room and then I discovered it was me
the crafter so it was um shocking really
the way they beat up everyone and then
they took me like some sort of a
terrorist I had no access to information
so I had no idea what was going on
outside once they abducted me
you describe it as an abduction who who
you blame
it was the Army which abducted me
and nothing happens without the
permission of the army Chief that's how
the Army works
so clearly he had ordered the abduction
we're hearing from the military and the
government that the security concerns
around you in the threat and risk has
been so high that this was the only
option that you forced their hand
you know this is such nonsense
first they attacked my house for 24
hours
they wanted me to appear in a in a court
in Islamabad in a magistrate court I had
already agreed to attend
the law says that had I give them an
assurity bond that I would attend the
court they couldn't arrest me they
refused to take the assurity bond
attacked my house for 24 hours we
couldn't sit inside there was always
tear gas shelling on the you know people
had broken bones and stuff so
the they are on a plan and what is the
plan the plan is they are petrified of
Elections the gap between us and all the
other parties is so huge now that
they're petrified that they will be
wiped out so they have decided that the
only way they'll allow elections is if
I'm inside jail or killed there are two
attempts been two attempts on me
and most of my senior leadership should
be jailed too this is what they've done
they've used this to put the entire
leadership of PTI in jail
what will you do if you're re-arrested
because there is a very real threat with
more than a hundred charges against you
that you could be
well on the last count it was 148 so I'm
reaching my century and a half
and they're all you know bizarre charges
like sedition I mean serious charges
that I've uh corrupted treasury the
corruption case on what you know what
was the corruption case what is your
strategy if you are re-arrested or low
strategy I am mentally prepared to go
into jail as I said before leaving for
Islam but I said I'm prepared
but the the point is that it is
their intention is not because I've
broken some law
the intention is that they want me out
of the Electoral race this is the
election year how do you lead with so
much of your party
in chair
well I mean I just the remnants I get
today today and I've had a meeting with
them and we're trying to talk out a
strategy I'm going to go out in public
and start my uh Mass contact from
Wednesday onwards so um well we will
carry on uh hoping that the Supreme
Court will announce an election date in
three weeks time can you reassure voters
that you're even going to be around for
it let alone your leadership the rest of
your party
look what might happen God Alone knows
what might happen I mean I have I'm
lucky to be alive
no one thought I would survive yesterday
because they had already got police
contingent from another province that
the moment I had got Bail from these
cases the police was ready to take me
in jail on another case but the judges
stood up
and this is what has shocked the
military establishment because the
judges finally decided they said look we
we're not going to again get him into
jail and everyone knows trumped-up
charges and the result would be public
unrest so the judges took a stand I mean
we are witness witnessing history in
Pakistan now the new history being
written your arrest sparked widespread
and violent protests we saw military
installations satellite houses attacked
government buildings do you condemn that
violence violence that the government
say you're in supporters carried out
I condemn I have always condemned all
violence
the military has been the Bedrock of
this country for decades do you think
you can run the nation without the
support of the army because you run that
risk of alienating them no look
look things change countries evolve
thinking of changes we started off as a
security state
and had straight away martial law with
the Army rule for 10 years but right now
I mean
I have never seen such oppression I mean
this total clampdown on media I can't
appear on live television if journalists
have picked up beaten up tortured
custodial torture of my senior members a
social media activists it's never
happened like this before this is the
same military that helps bring you to
power in the first place
seems like somewhat of an ideological
u-turn
absolutely not
they never brought me into Power I my
party was the most popular party all the
opinions Paul said that we won the
election but the Army didn't oppose me
that's that's the difference this feels
like like a very febrile moment when the
country is politically polarized
economically spiraling voters want to
see some hope how are you going to cool
things down and reassure them that
politics is even worth voting for right
this is the election year
elections are supposed to be held this
year
all if you want the solution to
Pakistan's problems the elections
hold free and fair elections let the
people decide who they want to give the
mandate
and Pakistan will stabilize problem is
that they are all worried the entire
12-party Coalition is petrified along
with the military establishment that my
party will sweep the elections because
out of 37 by-elections we have swept 30
of them so because they are worried
they're trying to delay the elections
that's all so all we want is free and
fair elections do you have faith in the
Judiciary and where do you think
democracy in Pakistan is right now
well the Democracy in Pakistan has never
taken such a battering as it has right
now
I'm in all of fundamental rights are
violated this sort of thing has never
happened no political figure has ever
had 100 almost 50 cases and then his
house raided once they attacked for 24
hours then when I was away they threw an
armored car they broke through my door
raided my house my wife was all alone by
herself it's never happened before so
democracy is an all-time low the only
hope we have is the Judiciary